okay wollen wir die
motivkarte was machst du
da
Spurenbeseitigung wo ist
Murat
Einkauf okay lass mich das noch kurz
wegmachen und
dann machen wir eine Motivtorte für
Halloween
ja
wie erkleicht es jetzt meinen
[Musik]
Zuschauern okay das war Spaß das hier
ist essbar ich habe mir dieses Jahr
nämlich für euch was ziemlich cooles
einfallen lassen eine Motivtorte die
wirklich jeder nachbacken kann einen
richtig coolen 3D Geist und ich habe
auch einige Deko Ideen für euch
vorbereitet die seht ihr dann auch als
Shorts oder res auf Social Media und ich
würde sagen ich packe jetzt kurz meine
Zutaten aus und leg direkt los mit dem
Pen denn es gibt jetzt erstmal einen
leckeren Schokokuchen den mag nämlich
jeder und mein Blut hier das WIS ich
jetzt weg und dann kann ich jetzt schön
Backen herzlich willkommen übrigens in
[Musik]
sell zuerst backe ich jetzt den Kuchen
dafür ne einen Schokoladenkuchen der
richtig schön saftig ist aber auch eine
gewisse Stabilität hat um später diesen
Geist zu formen und damit ihr es euch
einfacher machen könnt oder ich es euch
einfacher mache backen wir jetzt erstmal
einen Blechkuchen dafür verwendet ihr
sechs Eier 300 g Zucker eine Prise Salz
etwas Vanilleextrakt 300 g Milch 300 g
Sonnenblumenöl 450 g Mehl da könnt ihr
Weizen oder Dinkel verwenden 50 g Kakao
dre Teelöffel Backpulver 200 g gemahlene
Mandeln und wenn ihr wollt gerne noch
schwarze Lebensmittelfarbe damit der
Geist so richtig gruselig wird okay los
geht's für den Blechkuchen gebt ihr
jetzt zuerst die Eier in die
Rührschüssel der Zucker das Salz und
Vanilleextrakt kommen dazu und die
Zutaten werden jetzt für 5 bis 10
Minuten richtig schön cremig verrührt
damit sich die Farbe gut verteilt könnt
ihr jetzt auch gerne schon eure schwarze
Lebensmittelfarbe dazu geben und schön
mit einrühren und beim Backen mit
Lebensmittelfarbe ist es so dass ihr
wirklich gar nicht so viel
Lebensmittelfarbe braucht es reicht
wirklich wenn die Masse richtig schön
dunkelgrau wird denn beim Backen wird
die Farbe noch intensiver das heißt wenn
ihr ein kräftiges Schwarz haben wollt
reicht so eine dunkelgraue Farbe jetzt
kommen noch die zwei Flüssigkeiten mit
dazu und werden ganz kurz bei niedriger
Stufe eingerührt und damit sich die
trockenen Zutaten gut verbinden könnt
ihr jetzt einfach mehl mit Backpulver
vermischen Kakao dazu geben und die
gemahlenen Mandeln und alles nur noch
ganz kurz bei niedrigster Stufe
unterrühren jetzt kommt der Teig einfach
noch in meinem Backblech ich nehme jetzt
hier den Backrahmen habe eine schöne
große Backfläche und kann später den
Kuchen einfach ausschneiden oder
ausstechen ihr könnt natürlich auch wenn
ihr vier Tortenringe habt einfach zwei
etwas größere Backen mit 20 cm
Durchmesser und zwei etwas kleinere mit
15 cm Durchmesser jetzt kommt der Kuchen
schon in den Backofen und wird gebacken
und ich kann in der Zwischenzeit schon
eine ganase Herstellen der Kuchen ist
gebacken und abgekühlt ich habe ihn auch
schon im Kühlschrank damit er richtig
schön fest ist und zum Füllen nehme ich
jetzt eine ganach eine Zartbitter ganage
die könnt ihr einfach herstellen inem
ihr Sahne aufkocht zaritterchokolade
oder auch gern Vollmilchschokolade oder
weiße Schokolade dazu gibt ganz noch
eurem Geschmack das Rezept findet ihr
auch bereits in meiner App und auf dem
Blog und wenn ihr wollt dass die ganach
auch schwarz ist dann gebt ihr auch hier
schwarze Farbe dazu ihr könnt die
praktisch schon beim Aufkochen der Sahne
dazu geben denn wie ich schon erwähnt
habe wird die Farbe dunkler wenn sie
sich erhitzt ich habe jetzt hier die
ganage allerdings schon fertig das heißt
ich nehme eine kleine Menge rührfarbe
ein und geb sie ganz kurz in die
Mikrowelle das S nur ein bisschen warm
wird und dann habe ich ein schönes
schwarz
war ein Schreier aus dem Keller und wir
haben nicht mal ein du hast vergessen
ihn zu füttern oder es ist richtig
gruselig 10 Sekunden reichen schon die
garnasch soll nicht
verbrennen
perfekt jetzt einfach mit eurer ganach
verrühren ich find jetzt sieht man den
Unterschied ganz gut dann lasse ich die
jetzt kurz abgedeckt auf
Zimmertemperatur abkühlen hol noch
bisschen Orangenmarmelade die ich selbst
gemacht habe denn damit wird die Torte
dann
gefüllt jetzt habe ich mir mal Gedanken
gemacht wie mein Geist aussehen soll ich
glaube so ist ganz süß ja ein ganz
einfacher Geist okay ihr nehmt euch
jetzt euren Tortenboden der muss wie
gesagt schön kalt sein am besten aus dem
Kühlschrank hier ist die ganach hier ist
die Marmelade alle Rezepte verlenke ich
euch natürlich und der wird jetzt 3D
aufgebaut das heißt unten habe ich einen
Ring der ein bisschen größer ist falls
ihr keine Tortenringe habt nehmt ihr
einfach Schüsseln tellerschalen
irgendwas was rund ist oder schneidet
eben rund aus das geht natürlich auch
und für weiter oben nehme ich einfach
den burgerring der hat nämlich 10 cm
Durchmesser und das ist einfach perfekt
dann kann ich oben so ein bisschen den
Geist kleiner werden lassen ich ma jetzt
zwei so einmal 14 dann
12 ich glaub dass er nicht zu klein wird
oben mache ich noch ein
mittleren ihr könnt da ruhig auch mal so
zwei halbe
machen und aneinanders
setzen cool also der erste Boden ist da
nhmt ihr ein bisschen Marmelade einfach
eure Lieblingsmarmelade dann ganase
dazwischen und alle Böden übereinander
stapeln und es kann natürlich jetzt sein
dass das ganze noch bisschen zu instabil
ist W wenn ihr das merkt dann stellt sie
einfach zwischendurch kalt während ihr
sie füllt und stapelt ihr könnt auch
gerne die Tortenböden etwas dünner
zuschneiden ich muss sagen mich stört es
hier gar nicht und ich finde das
Verhältnis passt ganz
[Musik]
gut also so darf sie jetzt erstmal
aussehen und kommt in den Kühlschrank
bis sie richtig schön fest ist damit ich
sie dann anschlie zuschneiden
kann sieht komisch aus gehört aber
[Applaus]
so macht nichts die hau mal einfach
wieder
drauf ST gerade einfach runtergerutscht
ich sag doch wenn ihr zwischendurch die
Torte kühlen müsst dann kühlt sie ich
wollte gerade tatsächlich noch was
reinspießen als Hilfe aber wir sind in
dieser Küche und ich habe hier doch
nicht diese tortendübel Dinger
ist
Halloween sieh es noch ästhetisch
[Musik]
aus
grillspießcke kuchentest jetzt auch
getan dpie
perfekt passt doch we warum I was er
hat guck geht doch klappt doch er ist
fest ich hatte den jetzt einfach kurz im
gefrefach was soll ich sag's doch beim
Backen okay es kann schon einiges
schieflaufen aber man kriegt auch oft
wieder gerettet also jetzt macht ihr
einfach daraus eine schöne Geistform und
eine Geistform da gibt's keine
Definition dafür ihr macht die Geistform
so wie ihr sie gerne hättet das heißt
oben finde ich schon wichtig oben schön
rund dass es einen schönen Kopf hat und
nach unten hin kommt ja e vondant drüber
vielleicht schaffe ich sogar ihm zwei
Hände zu formen wer weiß sieht aus als
hätte ich mein backtalent verloren aber
es ist nicht so wer weiß
vielleicht doch vielleicht bin ich gar
nicht
s jetzt lacht ihr noch jetzt lacht ihr
noch alle später sagt ja e das aber ein
schöner Geist WD der vom Auto
überfahren schau mal auf de
Monitor wie das aussieht Daniela sag was
Anna lacht mich aus ja die lacht dich
[Musik]
an die Torte ist jetzt fertig modelliert
und steht im Kühlschrank damit sie noch
mal schön fest wird ich habe jetzt hier
bereits weißen Fondant mit CMC Pulver
verknetet also mit dem Pulver mit dem
Fondant einfach aushärtet ihr könnt aber
auch Fondant und Blütenpaste einfach ein
bisschen verknetet dann htet es auch aus
denn dann bleiben diese Falten auch
schön liegen jetzt einfach von weich
kneten und auf bäckerstärke
ausrollen war beim Training
heute liestützten Tag
und Muskeltraining und alles und
anstrengend danach Motivtorte zu
machen bist du da kannst du mich bitte
beim Ausrollen
unterstützen go more
Passion enery
enery ich dachte unterstützen ach so
okay okay komm sing weiter
okayerererer
klappt doch
tschüss Gott das ist mal eine Motivation
in der
Küche
danke creepy wenn sie fwork in der Küche
machen
würde er meinte foodwork wir Dichtens um
in
foodwork ja super machst du das
Wahnsinn
ich sag doch Tinas Workouts ich glaub
ich glaube jetzt ist groß genug ich
hoffe jetzt einfach dass es
reicht bitte drückt mir die Daumen es
ist
eine sehr knappe Geschichte aber es
wird so jetzt legen wir das so vorne
die
Arme einfach ein schönen faltigen Geist
legen süß das do süß jetzt machen
wir die Augen den Mund und mal gucken
vielleicht kommt noch so eine Gande als
Deko aber das weiß ich noch nicht
vielleicht auch nicht für die Augen
nehme ich einfach ein bisschen schwarzen
Fondant und halbiere die Kugel dann habe
ich gleich zwei gleich große Augen dann
zu kugelnformen bisschen flach drücken
und einfach mit etwas Wasser oder
etbkleber
aufkleben den Mund einfach auch so ein
bisschen länglicher Formen und auch
aufkleben dann formme ich jetzt hier
noch kleine Kugeln aus weißem Fondant
und es werden dann die Lichtpunkte im
Auge und wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr ihn
jetzt so lassen oder noch ein bisschen
schattieren ich habe jetzt hier rote und
schwarze Lebensmittelfarbe als Pulver
nehm trockene Pinsel und schortiert den
einfach noch ein bisschen und dann kann
er schon probiert werden und ich finde
es einfach so eine Torte die schnell
gemacht ist ganz einfach man kann nichts
falsch machen und sie ist echt richtig
süß ihr könnt sie natürlich auch
gruseliger machen aber ich wollte jetzt
hier auf dem Kanal nicht so eine richtig
gruselige Torte machen außerdem finde
ich sie so richtig süß Halloween kann ja
auch süß gruselig
sein sagte ich und habe ein
blutverschmiertes Messer auf meinem
Tisch ja
[Musik]
ihr könnt mich einstellen als
synchronisiererin ich hab es jetzt mal
bisschen gruseliger gemacht weil die
Torte nicht so gruselig ist jetzt kommt
Eugen der darf die Torte
probieren hello e du B mein Halloween
Opfer ich will nur sagen dass si richtig
cool aus ist echt echtes Blut ja von
wem sag ich da hast du m die letzten 3
Stunden gesehen
nein muss ich mir Sorgen
machen was hat er angestellt süß oder
guck mal guck mal hier a gucke mal W
jetzt gar nicht wie ich anfangen s
musste ich auch
nicht um ehrlich zu sein ja ich hatte
schon meinen Plan aber der
ging wir
Dönerspieß bisschen
schief dann habe ich Plan B ausgepackt
schön geworden ja die innen schwarz okay
ist okay wenn da bisschen Blut drauf ist
ja
ja okay sah auch schon mal appetitlicher
aus auf dem Teller aber Halloween das
gehört so der gehört so weil so perfekte
Kuchenstücke kann jeder ich würde dir
glaube ich nur empfehle mehr aus der
Mitte zu essen weil außen ist sehr viel
Creme der kann noch bisschen
durchziehen sag einfach schmeckt ja we
es schmeckt ja schmeckt m ah okay also
der schmeckt tsich nach einem Tag noch
besser weil dann die orangenmmelade
bisschen einzieht mir ein Tick zu
trocken tatsächlich
einmal unten probiert oder mehr in der
Mitte und außen außen schmeck schmeckt
mir sehr gut okay sieht aus als wde ich
jetzt ein verbrannte Kuchen essen ja
also ich hat erst auch so gedacht okay
was verbrann
nein was ich da ess ja Schokokuchen
schwarz gefärbt Geschmackstest bestanden
best sehr gut also dann wünsche ich euch
ganz viel Spaß falls Halloween feiert
schaut euch gerne auch die anderen
Videos an aus den letzten Jahren ganz
viele Rezeptideen habe ich da für euch
und ich habe noch einige Dekoideen für
euch gemacht wie ihr nämlich euren Tisch
oder euren Raum einfach richtig hübsch
dekorieren könnt schaut da gerne mal
vorbei und falls ihr kein Video mehr
verpassen wollt Abonniert ihr einfach
diesen Kanal und kommentiert auch gerne
die Videos bis zum nächsten Mal undter
eugin und ich wir haben übrigens wir
haben krass viele Videos gemacht wir
haben nämlich ein komplettes Wohnzimmer
Makeover gemacht und das kommt jetzt
auch ganz bald on online ja ganz bald
Anna kriegt schon Angst hin der Kamera
we sie sagt es war viel Material und VI
überlegen ob wir uns selbständig machen
sollen ja ich find ich finde e fin wir
sollten uns selbstständig machen okay
machen wir ja Eugen und selli die
handwerkersendung hey Leute ich bin
Murat und das ist mein Kumpel günny wir
haben wahrscheinlich momentan die
teuerste und spektakulärste
handwerkersendung im deutschen Fernsehen
geht jetzt direkt in die AD Mediathek
gibt dort ein Murat dreht am Rad und und
seht uns beim Handwerken wie wir
unglaubliche Dinge machen sag do auch
was fehlen die Worte ja mir
auch aber ich weiß wo das größte Problem
nachher liegen wird das Ding nach in der
in Auto reinzen meinst du die wollte das
wirklich so dunkel haben D schleib noch
mal ab geh weg
h ich will ich steich ab ich
sag h auf H auf ihr müsst mal Z
patherapie K boxampf zwei gehen rein
einer geht
[Gelächter]
raus aber hast du gar keine Angst dass
die jetzt z.B nicht glücklich sind mit
dem was du auslieferst vielleicht haben
die was anderes erwartet die Sendung
kann man so zamm schneiden das aussieht
dass du was
[Musik]
kannst